This is a poltergeist phenomenon
Everyone is
following you Get out
Leave it to the Destroyers It's
like a ghost It
's a blow with destruction magic It's a
cleansing magic Let's go
MoatCircle
Did you do it?
In the astral side
, you must have escaped to the spiritual world.If you escape to the spiritual world, you can't help
it.Well, there's
magic that can pass to the psychiatrist, but it
cooperates too much and blows away this ghost and this house.Do
you want to do it?
In fact, that ghost doesn't have any means of attack After
all,
I called it land.
Kanade's terror reached its peak, and her
body surpassed her spirit.
Probably
important.
No,
what have I been up to now
[music]